though it takes inspiration from isakai
stories in which people from Earth are
transported to and become trapped in
Fantastical World think Alice in
Wonderland but Japanese for spoken
ultimately doesn't understand what makes
that genre so popular instead it tells a
largely forgettable story that sets up
major Stakes but fails to offer a
compelling reason for why the player
should care luminous Productions action
RPG feels great when it allows you to
really stretch your legs and magically
parkour across its fantasy landscape the
combat is clunky and regular Exposition
2 often stalls the action where am I
what's happened to me
in full spoken protagonist Frey finds
herself trapped in the magical filled
world of Athea after stumbling through a
portal there she bonds with a sentient
brace she nicknames cuff and then
encounters a group of survivors living
in the last City that's free from the
effects of a dangerous miasma this
blight which Frey calls the break covers
the land and transforms living creatures
into mutated monsters Frey's The Only
Exception making her an ideal candidate
for exploring the break finding its
source and destroying it the whole
situation is an intriguing narrative
setup but it's let down by Boring or
unlikable characters it's difficult to
like the standoffish and stubborn Fray
the incessantly sarcastic cuff who
regularly quips and phrase ear like it
discounts Jarvis or any of the survivors
who are all too eager to completely rely
on phrase protection from the break
while also asking her to complete boring
optional tasks like going on a tour of a
lifeless Hub or petting a bunch of sheep
for spoken story is one about belonging
finding a place you want to stay and
people you wish to protect like any
isakai protagonist worth their salt Frey
is initially resistant to her new
surroundings before discovering that
she's actually ideally suited to the
world she's found herself trapped in
however it's not a world that the game
is able to adequately convince the
player of wanting to stay in and protect
the emotional connection for spoken
tries to establish to incentivize the
player to take action and help people is
deeply uninteresting and oftentimes head
scratching and odd the characters don't
take the threat of athea's imminent
destruction very seriously and any
tension that comes from their perilous
existence is repeatedly undermined by
meaningless busy work they want you to
do the characters themselves are also
incredibly plain with two-dimensional
personalities they have no real
convictions or anything interesting to
say the facial expressions of the people
in athia are stilted and uncomfortable
which already creates a bit of a
disconnect with the emotional core of
her spoken story but the issue is
exacerbated by how those people are
characterized and used to inspire Frey
we see Frey contemplate murderous
Vengeance over the death of a Survivor
she'd only just met and feel guilty over
belittling someone she has the slimmest
of connections to these people aren't
fleshed out in full spoken story and so
the way they emotionally manipulate Frey
isn't all that believable or fulfilling
to watch my playthrough was filled with
me constantly asking yes but why should
Frey care and forespoke never delivered
a satisfying answer to the question
they needed me what's wrong with that
people need each other
with not much keeping you within the
last Bastion of human life in Athea
you're encouraged to go out and explore
the wider World sprinting over fields
with phrase parkour abilities and
Blasting enemies away with explosive
magic Frey Zips through the environment
with stylish flips and jumps moving so
quickly that she skids to a halt this
does create an enjoyable fluidity to
movement and it's exhilarating to feel
the world speed past you but the lack of
precision makes platforming or levels
within enclosed spaces frustratingly
difficult whereas for spoken's movement
mechanics encourage a Wilder free-form
style of engaging with the world combat
pushes you toward Precision there's a
precise timing needed to pull off
Dodgers and parries and several of
phrase magic spells lend themselves to
careful placement and strategic use
that's difficult to do when racing
around the environment as a result for
spoken feels disjointed as the moments
of exploration and navigation come into
conflict with combat instead of
complementing each other these two parts
of the game are actively fighting one
other they never come together into a
cohesive whole Frey can let loose a wide
variety of bombastic spells and magical
abilities all of which are visually
impressive displays she can Crush
enemies with massive Boulders engulf
whole groups in a molten eruption or fry
everything around her with brilliant
green lightning it all looks very cool
but there's not much in the way of
strategy to it cough can inform Frey
what flavor of her magic is most
effective against a particular enemy and
then all you have to do is switch to
that element and keep tossing attacks
out early into the game you encounter
enemy types that encourage you to think
a bit beyond that enemies who can block
Magic from the front or foes who can't
be damaged until you destroy their wings
for example but they only really appear
in the first quarter of the story after
that most enemies are bullet sponges
designed to create challenge in how much
of a magical beating they can take it's
not hard to switch to Magic types to
mindlessly exploit weaknesses and so
combat the visually impressive quickly
loses all sense of enjoyment for
spoken's movement is far fun especially
in the latter half of the game when you
start unlocking and chaining new
mechanics that increase the variety of
ways that free can journey across athia
like slingshotting herself through the
air with a flaming whip or manipulating
gravity to skate across water even if
there's nowhere interesting to go in
full spoken its open world is dotted
with an assortment of run-of-the-mill
side quests like time limited parkour
challenges and photo ops it's fun to be
had on the act of Simply getting to your
next main mission Exposition regularly
cuts into the experience however Frey
and cuff quip a lot and even though cuff
does have a few humorous one-liners and
insightful commentary on the world of
athia over the course of the story Frey
does not gotta keep moving time is money
Frey is one of the weakest parts of
forespoken her characterization
resembles the narrative Arc of 90s and
early 2000s isakai light novels Manga
and Anime which largely focused on
female protagonists becoming trapped in
another world there they discovered
their innate talents translated into
Power which they wield in a quest that
awarded them personal agency and
self-confidence but Frey deviates from
these isakai protagonists she's
inherently unlikable for most of all
spoken story with the game forcing her
through her transformation from selfish
sorcerer to defiant hero over the course
of a single chapter of lengthy
Exposition I didn't buy into her heroic
shift in the final moments of the game
it felt like the storyline was going
through the motions without taking the
necessary steps to ensure Frey's
emotional and mental development made
sense as a character Frey feels flat my
introduction to her is seeing her on the
wrong side of a criminal court case and
that she views the world around her with
jaded exasperation she pushes people
away because she's an abandoned orphan
and believes no one wants her Frey
carries that disposition throughout most
of the game and is the primary means by
which she views every aspect of Athea
and thus the way we the player are able
to see it forespoken doesn't do anything
to celebrate Frey as someone who is
black or a woman or anything else about
her the game posits that the only
perspective worth noting from Frey is
that out of an orphan and that
restriction not only stunts the
character growth she can achieve but it
also just gets stale after a few hours
yeah that sounds about right people only
give a [__] when they want something
from you forespoken is a tricky game to
recommend the law of its world is
interesting but delivered in a stilted
expository Manner and the freeing
sensation of taking off across the
landscape in a magically propelled
Sprint is sullied by the knowledge that
there's nowhere to go or anything fun to
do combat is visually impressive but not
all that engaging and the excellent
sound design and catchy musical score is
regularly undermined by unfun equips
from an unlikable protagonist I enjoyed
parts of it but too often my fun was
dragged to an unrewarding halt
[Music]